yuria defiled and dressed in rags
you might not mark her as a witch if not
for that iconic
pointed hat legends attest that witches
have been wearing this peculiar style of
headwear since
long ago which implies that magic women
were common back then tour the nexus and
you'll find a plethora of statues
depicting women
wrapped in robes masked by hoods
befriend the monumental and she reveals
that
she too is female for in demon souls
women have a unique capacity for the
soul arts
for them sorcery is commonly this art of
emotion
it's intuited from feeling rather than
developed through contemplation freak
wields a different type of magic from my
witchcraft
freak's magic stems from an
understanding of the essence of the
demon soul
while my witchcraft merely channels its
energy
if the demon is cursed so shall be the
craft
frake's power comes from human potential
while mine is a dark dependent art
so when you find a demon soul you take
it to uria
to manifest its power not freak i
feel great misgivings about fake
i was branded a witch at a very young
age
and have been persecuted ever since
[Music]
although i never had ill intentions this
black craft of mine is intrinsically
evil
if there is a god he gave us souls to do
good not to practice witchcraft
my accusers detested my dark arts for
good reason
for the past i have taken is tainted
but i am afraid that frank too
has ventured down the wrong path he has
become obsessed with the dark arts
the dark arts and witches have an evil
reputation
because here in this nexus years ago
women
seem to have done what men could not
here
their unique proficiency for soul magic
was used to its fullest potential
to worship to study and to eventually
awaken
the old one this led to the first
scourge
to demons and to the defilement of half
the world
if there was any one member responsible
for awakening the old one then it was
the maiden in black
this witch demonstrates a motherly
tenderness with the demon and was one of
its most powerful servants
during this time like other witches she
would have channeled its power
and the power of the old one was dark
indeed
the old one's magic is to absorb souls
claiming them
through a network of demons in the fog
skewered with spears
likely dropped from the nexus the old
one appears to be
unkillable so with countless souls lost
the fabric of reality broken and all
their kingdoms reduced to ruin
the monumentals appear to have settled
for a half measure
they forced the old one into slumber
imprisoned it in their sky temple
and took it to the far reaches of human
habitation
where they hoped the beast might never
be disturbed again
the maiden defiled and dressed in black
was blinded with wax and forced to tend
to the candles within the shrine
she is the shame of the monumentals a
disastrous product of their culture's
obsession
with magic countless people would have
ended up displaced from this
and the all-consuming fog would have
also exacerbated the
number of impoverished refugees busy
with the war
no nation would have accepted these poor
men and women
forcing them all to wander the earth to
repair the fabric of reality
six arch stones were constructed and
given to the remaining leaders of men
the ambitious king the digger king
the intelligent queen the priest to the
shadow men
the giants and yes even to the chief
of those wandering poor starved of magic
during this period many of these
cultures collapsed
this would have affected the poor people
of the world with no magic arts to heal
them
and no nation welcoming them the chief
of these vagrants
led them deep into the western valley
where no one would mind
their poverty this place it's a proper
mound of rubbish
all the rot of the world living or not
ends up here
here anarchy reigns the poor scavenge
for food
shelter and wares diseased vermin bite
and
suck their soiled skin merchants lie and
cheat
and a cannibal even roams the swamp
it should come as no surprise then that
the chief's duty to their archstone was
quickly forgotten why should they care
about the outside world when
it had all but abandoned them to make
matters worse
above a new religion was gaining power
a priesthood from the land of merde
whose
temples quickly came to span the
continent
especially in the western highlands they
had a belief
in a singular deity a god who seeks all
that is pure and
good and rejects all that is perceived
to be
impure and evil as a result we see
higher ranking priests achieve
saintly status by remaining pure in
every sense
sequestering themselves in their temples
devoted to prayer
reciting miracles that reject death
selfishness disease
poison but most reviled of all
was magic it was those evil sorcerers
and magicians that caused a near
apocalypse
so the priest's anti-magic stance would
have made their religion
ripe for popularity they built upon the
monumental's ban
on soul magic taking steps to oppress
any who practice the craft regardless of
intentions or circumstance
and yuria serves as our foremost example
of this
now while the soul arts are a distant
memory at this point in history
artifacts from this bygone age still
exist
take the ring of magical nature for
example cursed witches were believed to
be born holding
this ring making artifacts like these
objects of extreme fear and superstition
unless the church found them of course
then they were considered
divine revelations instead for example
there was the moonlight sword
granted to temple night vitso the
esterell
given to temple knight rezaiah blind
given to selen vinland
and brampt taken up by her brother gal
but perhaps most special of all was a
ring
of sincere prayer an artifact found by a
truly lucky young girl
leading to her instant rise as the sixth
saint
astraya so is she a saint
or a witch it's here that we arrive at
the biggest twist that demon souls has
to offer
that magic and miracles are two sides of
the same coin
and that the old one is at the heart of
it all
why else would all of the most powerful
saints of the temple
be women why else were miracles
energized alongside magic
when the old one was awakened why did
the priest's
talismans of god resemble the old one
it's simple because their so-called god
is
the old one his miracles are the soul
arts
and women can more easily channel this
magic
whether they be witches or saints prayer
is for the foolish quaint and soon to be
dead
and heaven forbid the day you find out
what their so-called
god really is the temple believes
whatever best suits their politics so
when they cast their arrogant gaze
towards the denizens of the valley
they didn't see the needy they saw
sinners being punished by god
however this couldn't be farther from
the truth i find something odd about
this place
it brims with grime
but at once feels strangely pure the
lost and
unclean are simply victims of
circumstance
circumstances that the temple helped to
create when they abandoned them
circumstances that astraya the sixth
saint
set out to resolve during the early days
of the second scourge
astraya was quick to embark on a relief
mission to boletaria
and in the years after entering the tear
she discovered the existence of the
valley
how many years has it been that witches
trier came to this valley with that
squid-headed night
those ridiculous white robes of hers
i swear i caught her glaring at my son
in disgust
yes yes it's true she is as nasty as
they come
for a woman whose luck saved her from
both poverty and plague
seeing the poor and afflicted came as a
shock
which the filthy woman misinterprets
here as contempt
in truth the clergy woman's heart ached
for their suffering
and unlike her peers in the church she
came from nothing
so she better understood their plight
and so she began to question for the
first time
why had god permitted their pain if
there is a natural evil it is not those
who were forced to live in the valley
it is god so cruel and unjust to allow
suffering in his creation
and so astraya chose to bring salvation
to those people abandoned
just like the trash of the valley but
healing magic can only go
so far in order to reach the root of the
problem
she needed to take away the source of
thoughts which bring
pain the soul and so she became an
archdemon for the old one
gaining the power to rob the living of
their souls she embraced the filthy
ridding them of their suffering and for
that they revere her
all the men worship her the same men who
would snatch my child away from me
astraya sits on a mountain of gold and
corpses
both are offerings from the men of the
valley who are
desperate to repay their debt to the
woman who love them
any soul will do making it a terrifying
place for people like the filthy woman
and the temple knights who embarked in
pilgrimage here
have you heard the rumors about estrella
of the valley of defilement
they claim that she and her royal knight
have become
demons and lead a clan of degenerate
miscreants
in truth the rumors are surely unfounded
there are all sorts of wrongdoers down
there who would think up such
nonsense yet if the rumors are true
then may she be eternally damned for her
debasement of the lord's name
by this point her bodyguard garl vinland
should have stepped in and purified her
for her sacrilege
he came from a truly noble and powerful
family within the temple
so he risks everything by standing by
her side
but of course he had to he had seen
the same things that she had and the
knight would have been inspired by her
sincere faith
so he bravely stood in solidarity with
her decision
how dare you persist in intruding upon
our haven
you abandoned us long ago what right do
you have
but good intentions do not make you
immune from spreading evil
instead here this simply heightens the
tragedy
[Music]
dearest astraya i have failed you
you killed him didn't you very well
i can no longer resist you do as you
like
take your precious demon soul
destroyer defiled and dressed in white
has a soul that grants
spells of death relief and resurrection
she is at once the most impure demon
of them all but also closer to god than
any saint
before her so ask yourself slayer of
demons
do the ends justify the means
so i love making lore videos but i like
listening to lore as well
and one of my favorite things to listen
to right now is mythos
it's a collection of greek myths on
audible and it's an audio book that you
can listen to for free
during your 30-day audible trial so i'm
going to play a sample and while you
listen to it go and visit audible.com
or text vaatividia to 500 500
and you'll be able to start your free
trial right now
the shattered world was still smoking
from the savagery of war
zeus saw that it needed to heal
and he knew that his own generation the
third order of divine beings
must manage better than the first two
had done
it was time for a new order an order
purged of the wasteful bloodlust and
elemental brutality that had marked
earlier times
to the victors the spoils like a chief
executive who has just completed a
hostile takeover
zeus wanted the old management out and
his
people in so many of the games that we
enjoy
are influenced by greek mythologies and
it's just great to have a deeper
understanding of these things more
importantly
perhaps mythos is also excellently
narrated by stephen fry
and it allows him to perfectly recount
his many jokes and witticisms
keeping you entertained throughout when
you get an audio book that is narrated
by the person who wrote it
it just adds an extra layer to that
experience
because they know exactly how to present
what they're saying
before i go remember your membership
also includes access to their plus
catalogue which
grants unlimited access to thousands of
select originals audiobooks and podcasts
so no matter what you're into they've
probably got it
so again go and visit audible.com varity
video or text
variety vaatividia to 500 500 to get
started today
and thank you to audible for sponsoring
this video